évaluer la portée d'un tel travail dans le mode
le temps réel est parfois très difficile
impossible mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous sommes sûrs
on peut dire que l'ère d'alexandre 3
nous donne un exemple de naturel
combinaison harmonieuse d'échelle
industriel technologique
réformes gouvernementales et
fidélité
traditions et culture nationales
origines originales que je veux souligner et
aujourd'hui dans la dynamique turbulente du 21ème siècle
quand le changement touche tous les domaines
vie, il est important pour nous de préserver le patrimoine historique et
patrimoine culturel et spirituel de la Russie
des valeurs qui unissent nos hommes et
c'est pourquoi nous allons lancer de nouveaux
projet éducatif et porter une attention particulière
attention à l'éducation patriotique
les jeunes